il était 23h30 résultat du scrutin quand
le texte a été voté au Sénat pour
195 contre 112 le Sénat à adopté avec 24
heures d'avance
[Applaudissements]
conséquence d'une décision du groupe les
républicains qui a retiré environ 200
sous amendements prochaine étape la
commission mixte paritaire d'un côté
cette sénateurs de l'autre cette députée
l'objectif trouver un accord le texte
devra ensuite être voté jeudi d'abord au
Sénat à 9 heures puis à l'Assemblée à
15h officiellement sérénité affichée
issues du ministre nous sommes
convaincus qu'une majorité existe autour
ce texte quand on s'appelle Monsieur
Olivier du socle et qu'on a fait passer
une réforme de cette nature là qu'on
laisse la gauche tranquille qu'il aille
se regarder dans la glace savoir si il
est donc on a en phase avec sa
conscience moi j'ai connu un jeune qui
était combattant qui était de gauche qui
sur les tribunaux les bons l'Assemblée
nationale était plutôt quelqu'un
brillant là franchement c'est triste de
finir comme ça nous avons voulu agir et
cette réforme nous l'avons voulu c'est
notre réforme nous l'avons modifié c'est
notre texte que nous allons voter aux
raisonne sur la réforme des retraites
comme si il y avait pas le changement
climatique comme si aucun des paramètres
qui justifient la réforme n'allait être
percuté par le changement climatique
alors que rien
c'est une loi qui sera vraiment je pèse
mes mots un désastre social les
conséquences vont être terribles c'est
une loi aussi productiviste finalement
cette réforme c'est aussi une garantie
anti-impôt en plus pour les années à
venir pour financer notre système de
retraite si moi je pense que dans les
dans le débat qu'il y aura et le vote
qu'il y aura chaque voie en moins pour
la réforme des retraites ce sera quelque
part une voix pour plus d'impôts pour
les français dans les années à venir ce
qu'on souhaite pas et le changement
climatique va transformer les conditions
de travail il y a certains métiers qui
vont devenir plus pénibles le changement
climatique va amener également des
migrations en France qui vont aussi
évidemment contribuer
en compte et puis surtout le changement
climatique va altérer quand même
considérablement notre espérance de vie
Emmanuel Macron va répondre au syndicat
hier ils ont envoyé un courrier au
président de la République dans une
lettre de deux pages Emmanuel Macron
leur adresse une fin de non-recevoir je
ne sous-estime pas le mécontentement
dont vous faites le porte-parole comme
les angoisses exprimées par de nombreux
Français inquiets de ne jamais avoir de
retraite le gouvernement est comme il a
toujours été à votre écoute pour avancer
par le dialogue quand vous tapez sur la
tête des gens en permanence ils fin pas
répondre par la violence ce sera sa
responsabilité on lui a écrit nous on
s'en lavera les mains
je pense que vous êtes dingue si vous
êtes une personne qui travaille dur vous
voulez travailler parce que vous avez
quelque chose à apporter à la société
si vous rejetez la réforme
le chef de l'État a été filmé et même
photographié une bière à la main aux
côtés de plusieurs personnalités
congolaises une scène qui a été très
commentée et accompagnée d'arrêt sur
image peu flatteur vous le voyez et
surtout d'une autre photo où Emmanuel
Macron se fait tirer par le bras tout ça
pour justifier un soi-disant état des
briété avancé sauf que et ben ce dernier
cliché date en réalité de 2018 je vous
redis volontiers est-ce que la première
ministre a déjà eu l'occasion de dire
nous ne voulons pas de 49-3 nous
souhaitons transformer notre majorité
relative en majorité absolue sur le
texte des retraites et nous nous sommes
donné les moyens de le faire le 49-3
c'est constitutionnel c'est un outil
légal et donc vous ne trouverez jamais
la CFDT pour dire que c'est
antidémocratique ça pose un vice
démocratique ça pose un vice dém
pratique si on est obligé d'aller sur
des procédures parlementaires qui sont
escamotés au moment où s'exprime dans la
rue et dans l'opinion un mouvement de
contestation puissant contre cette
réforme non ce qui est légal n'est pas
forcément démocratique que le mot
démocratie c'est l'expression du peuple
c'est le respect du peuple c'est pas
vrai que dans cette affaire-là le peuple
va être respecté loin de là donc c'est
légal oui mais c'est pas démocratique
qui est Thierry casasnovas celui qui se
présente comme naturopathe au 600 000
abonnés sur sa chaîne Youtube cumule
aussi les signalements auprès de la
mission ministérielle contre les dérives
sectaires le youtubeur qui compte près
de 95 millions de vues et désormais mise
en examen soupçonné entre autres
d'exercices inégal de la médecine et
d'abus de confiance sans aucune
formation médicale Thierry casasnova
s'explique depuis une douzaine d'années
à ces quelques 600 000 abonnés que le
corps peut se régénérer sans traitement
ni médical
bien que personne dont la thyroïde a
repousser qu'en réalité la maladie
n'existe pas que les médecins mentent et
que la médecine moderne est en fait une
arnaque pour soigner le covid par
exemple voici ce qu'il propose un petit
peu de jus de carotte et vas-y vas-y que
je te que je t'envoie il prétend même
écouter bien que si on vous a amputé un
membre un jus de légumes bien choisi
peut le faire repousser voilà voilà le
genre de délire qu'on trouve dans les
heures et les heures de blabla de ce
gourou du jus et du jeune comme
l'appelle Libé Dieu parle par ma bouche
au style carrément une entreprise qui
donne des formations qui qui
fonctionnent et qui n'est pas plus
véreuse que toutes les autres
entreprises en France le présumé gourou
est également mis en examen pour
blanchiment selon les enquêteurs des
montages financiers douteux lui aurait
rapporté près de 3 millions d'euros
une manne engrangée grâce à sa chaîne
Youtube son site internet ces pseudos
manuels de naturopathie ou encore ses
séjours où l'on pratique le jeûne